for Senator John fetterman has just
checked himself into Walter Reed for
depression you know he was in a hospital
he was GW Medical Center a week or two
ago and people were wondering is this
another stroke is this he's had health
problems since the campaign's real since
he had a major stroke that even the New
York Times reports has rendered him
unable to process a lot of language he
has difficulty speaking he has
difficulty understanding words
especially when he's stressed and being
a senator is a stressful job
it's good that he's getting help it's
good that he's he's saying I can't take
this right now and he's you know a lot
better than the alternative but
Democrats need to let this poor man go
home